(mid-tempo bright music)
- [Narrator] In a remote part of Japan
lives a highly toxic
plant called the cycad.
And, believe it or not,
people consume it regularly.
Beloved and cherished by the
native people of Amami Ōshima,
eating the plant in its
raw form could kill you.
(mid-tempo upbeat music)
Amami Ōshima is home to to hundreds
of types of toxic plants.
The cycad has been a staple crop
on the island for generations.
Because it is so poisonous,
locals take the necessary steps
to make the plant safe
for human consumption.
- [Narrator] Through the process
of fermentation and drying,
the poison is extracted from the plant.
(machine beeps)
(slow gentle music)
(slow tranquil music)